-How are you, Kristen?
-Hi, Seth.
Great to see you.
I'm doing great.
I'm trying to get a few Z'
before tomorrow night.
It's gonna be a marathon,
I'm anticipating.
It's great to see you.
-I think a lot of people
are worried about insanity
in the coming days,
and, also, a lot of people
feel gratitude
towards you for the sanity
you brought to the proceedings
in the second
presidential debate.
You even got positive feedback
from President Trump.
What was it like hearing tha
he thought you did a good job?
-Well, first of all, thank you
so much for your nice comments
It was nice that people
on both sides of the aisle
felt as though it had gone well.
My goal, really, Seth,
was just to make sure
that it was a good discussion.
To prepare, I reached out to
voters, undecided voters,
Democrats, Republicans,
Independents,
and so I got a sense of what
voters wanted to hear about,
everything from healthcare
to the economy.
And so I really tried
to bring that to the debate.
And I was really relieved
that people felt as though
it was a good discussion.
That was my goal.
-I had doubts about the mute
button being effective...
-[ Laughs ]
-...but it seems, though,
even the threat of one
had an impact.
And we did get to hear
both candidates talk more.
I know prep is a key
to any debate moderation.
What did you plan for
in the days leading up for it?
-Well, we literally planne
for every scenario.
And in order to prepare, I mean,
I spent hours every single day
from like 6:00 a.m.
in the morning until midnigh
thinking about
every single question,
crafting every single question
But part of the prep
was just mental preparation,
so I have to give props to m
husband and also to Cody Rigsby,
my Peloton instructor,
because I worked out with him,
like, every day
to relieve stress.
And he's this great motivator.
And he would say things like
"I know you're feeling stressed.
I know everyone's
going through a lot,"
and I wanted to just say,
"Cody, you have no idea
what I am preparing for."
So, that's how I got prepare
and got through those days
leading up to the debate.
-I can only imagine there'
a great deal of preparatio
for tomorrow, as well.
One thing that everyone
seems to be preparing for is
one, not knowing
an outcome tomorrow,
and, two, the very real
possibility that the President
will announce an outcome.
How are news anchors,
news reporters,
bracing for
these two likelihoods?
-We're gonna be prepared
for any and all possibility,
just like any breaking-new
event that we would be covering.
And, really, Seth, it's just
about giving people the facts,
making sure that we are
covering things in real time
as they happen, and making sur
that we're getting it right.
That's the most important part
I think of being a journalist.
And so that's what we're
going to endeavor to do
throughout the day tomorro
as we cover what's gonna b
a really historic election here.
-You got sort of as high
a praise as you could get.
You were played
by Maya Rudolph on "SNL."
You must have known
to some degree that was coming
What was it like seeing yourself
portrayed on "SNL"?
-I have to say,
I was almost as anxious
thinking about
being portrayed on "SNL"
as I was about doing the debate.
But what an honor to be
portrayed by Maya Rudolph!
She is one of my favorites
I am just in awe of her
as an actress, as a comedian
I was literally -- had my face
pressed against the TV
like that, laughing,
and just sort of screaming
It was a little surreal.
And I thought
she did a great job.
It was so much fun.
I was glad that there was
a lot of focus
on the candidates, as well
I do have to say, though, Seth
for the record,
I'm not really a shot girl
I don't do shots.
That was a part of the skit.
I'm more of a sauvignon blan
kind of a girl.
But it was a lot of fun.
-Alright, that is good to know
As far as what "SNL"
could get wrong about you,
it's not the worst.
-[ Laughs ]
Exactly.
It was so much fun.
-You avoided not only
a disaster at the debate,
but you also avoided a disaste
a while back while you were with
Andrea Mitchell, your colleague.
Can we take a look
at this clip real quick?
-So it is quite remarkable
It's not exactly clear.
Politics -- Ooh!
It's a little windy
out here, Andrea.
-I mean, really good maintaining
of the composure there, Kristen.
-You know, I didn't have -
know that I had those reflexes
until that happened.
To be totally truthful, though
Seth, it looked
a lot scarier on TV.
And Andrea, who I refer to
as my D.C. Mom,
had this reaction
of just sheer terror.
You can hear her gasp
when those light stands
started falling in front of me
and my mom said,
"You know, I'm so glad
she reacted that way,
because that's how
I was reacting
when I was watching
on my living-room couch."
So I think she sort of brought
what a lot of moms
were feeling in that moment.
It was lot of fun, though,
and I had some fun with it
I started tweeting
at the Eagles --
of course, my hometown team.
I'm from Philadelphia,
and saying, you know,
I was ready for the draft pick
which was going on
at that time, so...
-It was very nice
that the Eagles noticed.
And as a fellow football fan
I can only tell you,
when your football team
knows you exist,
there's no higher praise.
-Yeah.
It was definitely
a great, great day.
And, in fact,
I'm in Philly right now, Seth,
to cover the election
and all of
the last-minute campaign stops
that are going on.
And so, really excited about
the Eagles win this weekend.
-Hopefully it'll put everybody
in a good mood
and get them out
to the polls tomorrow.
Have a great day tomorrow.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Really nice talking to you,
Kristen.
-Thanks for having me on.
I really appreciate it.
So much fun.